rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message be
creative
over to you Joe Rogan we were talking
before the this podcast about Holly
Holmes victory over Ronda Rousey and one
of the things that we were talking about
was that Ronda had this very linear
straight forward attack you knew she was
coming and Holly is a master at
countering so all she had to do was wait
and move and Ronda was coming in one
direction there was no there was there
was no variations no created there was
no creativity it was a mad bulldog rush
that had worked on everybody else before
but she found one person who was a
virtuoso at movement and she needed
creativity and it wasn't there and she
needed that experience that came with
having faced someone who knew that
position and nunu had a deep
understanding of that movement and she
didn't have that in her repertoire and
so that's the result that we saw like a
striker like Anderson Silva is extremely
creative if you watch he's got a fight
versus Tony Frick 'ln in Cage Warriors
Cage Warriors what was it called in
England small organisation in England I
think yeah where he practiced this step
in upper cut elbow like a sideways elbow
and his coach was going crazy stop
practising that and he would make his
wife hold the pillow because his his
coach didn't want him to practice it
anymore because he thought he was
wasting his time so he practice stepping
his wife and hold a pillow for him and
he'd step in and throw this upper cut
elbow that's what he knocked out
freckling with and he obviously the
frick 'ln was out class in that fight
but he wanted to make a point and the
front kick that heel and in the face of
Vitor Belfort Vitor never saw that chick
coming because nobody had done that to
him before because nobody had done that
in the history of the UFC nobody had
ever knocked anybody out with the first
kick you learn in martial arts but the
creativity to try something like that he
would throw punches to your thigh from
standing he would throw a jab to your
thigh he would throw a Crescent kick
inside Crescent kick to your face like
what the it was it was part of what made
him such an effective striker is that he
threw these things that you just didn't
expect him to do your ultimate success
will come from doing something in a
creative way that has never been done
before in your own style now I'm a big
believer in Milan success I think
whenever you don't know what to do
you're new to an industry you're new to
you're new to a country you need
anything
study success is it's the name with its
channels why I started doing this I
believe you can learn a lot by studying
the people who have come before you it's
how my first company was saved
I studied Bill Gates and success and it
took me from making $300 a month to
having companies as customers in 30
countries and being acquired a couple
years later like that strategy saved my
business and saved myself worth modeling
his success but doing what Bill Gates
did was not the exact same thing that
what I did I had the trial of Bill Gates
date and then modify it and that's the
key you take what works for these
different people and then you modify it
for yourself you have to put your own
twist on it you got to put your own
unique take on it because otherwise
you're just a copy of somebody else and
you won't be a good copy I look at my
youtube channel we've had we've done
some iconic things we've done the top 10
moves to success we've done the in
special series we've done a lot of
things that now other people are trying
to copy people send me emails all the
time but they leave comments on YouTube
saying hey this person's copying news
first and as the same template the same
idea they're they're doing the same
thing as you so like you can't out Evan
Evan if all you're doing is copying
exactly what I'm doing you're gonna lose
copy do exactly what I'm doing
you're gonna have to modify it if you're
just a junior Evan then you always lose
and that sucks for everybody because I
don't want to see a bunch of junior
Evans out there I want to see people
doing their thing I want to see you take
what I'm doing and improve on it make it
your own and have a different target
audience like have something that people
really love and look up to and can't
wait to see if all you're doing is a
mini version of me then why are people
gonna really pay attention to you right
like they're gonna come to me so that's
the thing
you have to be creative you can start by
copying other people you look at people
that you look up to respected who love
Oprah study her story see what she did
learn from those lessons success leaves
Clues absolutely that's what I preach
all the time in these videos but when
you apply it it should feel a little bit
odd it should feel like if I just copy
and paste it's not quite the whole thing
you're like 95% of the way there but
that extra 5% that's the genius that you
need to apply yourself that's what you
need to bring to it the magic that you
and only you can do if you get up and
start preaching believe you can't you
can't do it like me it's not that I'm
great there I'm better than anybody else
I'm just better being me than anybody
you're better being you so go be you
like you can't be better at Steve Jobs
and Steve Jobs no so that's the point
you can model success I'm a big fan of
it but at some point you need to be
creative you got to find your own path
you got to find your own place to stand
and that's exciting it's scary but it's
exciting and the gut check that I always
used was I would copy it exactly and did
you see what felt not right
I felt like hmm this piece here that's
missing you know people would give me
challenges and assignments and I would
try to do it it would never quite feel
right and I would always have to find a
way to customize it and tweak it even
when you guys leave suggestions and
feedback and do this topic sometimes is
a fit sometimes they need to like it
always has a bit of effort into it right
like all the videos that I launched have
me have believed I see them whether I'm
in the video or not as a piece of me
because that's what my channel is about
and it can't be replicated and so you
want everything you create that have a
piece of you in it
even if you're modeling from other
people you need to have that creativity
nurture it be excited by it study it and
whenever you have that little feeling
that something doesn't feel quite right
to hear something needs to be improved
here I know I can do better get excited
that's where you're gonna create some
magic when you feel a little bit of
restlessness jump into it don't run away
from it
don't hide under the covers jump into
that restlessness because from there
you're gonna create something amazing
that only you can do and then people out
there will try to be doing your versions
at you
and you can give them the same message
so the question they today is I'm
curious what is the most creative thing
that you have done in the past week
let's let's have some creativity
happening here in the comments leave it
down in the section below I'm excited to
see what you guys have to say I also
want to give a quick shout out to Adam
Travers I don't thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book the one
where it really means a lot to be made
and I hope you enjoyed so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you and
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events Bessette
[Music]
so I saw Natalie the flow assist video
and she had a convulsion so beautiful
and I was also working in a job that I
was frustrated with and trying to get
opera blood girl off the ground I've
tweeted something like man I wish I had
an excuse like I wish someone would just
break up with me so that I could have an
excuse to shave my hair off and then I
was like oh that's a funny plot line of
like a show or something and decided
like to tweet that I was gonna or put on
Facebook that I wanted to shave my head
bald and so all my friends responded
like oh my gosh do it you've got to be
so ugly oh my god what if you have a
weird-shaped head and I was like my
friends are terrible but I saw how much
attention I was getting and I was like
oh my gosh I should use this I should
shave my head and then do a trailer for
awkward black girl where I I feature my
bald head and that way people who want
to see what I look like will also know
about this new show that I'm trying to
do and so I did it and it got like 3,000
views in a day and I had a bald head now
I had a first start and that bought had
changed my life and my mom always knew
with singing that was my very strong
suit you know I grew up singing in a
church and my mom said when she saw me
sing that's really all the things that
gave her like you know what I feel
really like my daughter has something
powerful she thought that they could get
people to immediately see why she drove
for days and three nights you know from
her hometown
tell me pursue my dreams but everywhere
we went I mean it was usually mostly for
acting stuff cuz people wasn't aiming in
Michael Jackson's time people wasn't
really signing kid acts and so even
though my strongest suit was music we
still I still wanted to enter the world
of acting and so we thought what a great
idea would be to try to trick these
people and let me sing in the room so
they could see that she might not have a
lot of experience with acting but she's
got a lot of guts and she's got a lot of
uh you know passion so we go into these
rooms you know we'd have a quick
conversation that people would be you
know they see a million people all the
time they was ready to go after a little
while and my mom well you know we get
ready to go as soon as we're about to
get ready gob saying you know what can I
just sing for you please and then my mom
you know Kiki yeah they're not here
any of these things they don't have the
time for none of that and I'm like but
please please just let me sing for you
please and no honey no honey just let
her sing be a liar in your own leg it's
just so funny when I think when I'm Lily
think back on that type of stuff it is
so funny because my mom and I really did
have game plans and I think like
seriously we had a game plan and when we
go out the room we ladies thank you
thank you
high-fiving and everything in like that
is the best I remember I always tell my
mom we have a thing it's like I tell my
mom all the time like you my soulmate
girl you my soulmate you know me I know
that moms and daughters and parents they
have maternal relationships but my mom
and ours is more than that she
understands me and she has compassion
for me because she shares the same love
that I have for for creativity for me I
always like a director with good balance
and what I mean by good balance is
enough vision number one and then enough
freedom for the actors to be able to do
their jobs so I the style of acting that
I choose to take for each role I love to
be the character I love to becoming not
in a method type of way but in a scene I
like to watch a movie I'm in back and
feel like I can't remember doing that
stuff by watching Star Wars half of the
things Finn does in that film I can't
remember making the decision to do it
because it was a there was instinct and
there was freedom and there was the
ability to be able to be creative and JJ
is a big advocate of that I mean he
would we would start a scene with the
dialogue and he'll be like all right
let's just do your version and let's
just do a version that you guys feel
free with and that's how Harrison works
as well and improv really makes way for
magical moments and when you have a
director that has a good enough balance
to understand the technical point of
view for at least a good shot
color correction visual effects
practical effects but then he has
artistic knowledge also for character
arcs dialogue and and fun it's always
good so that's what I love raise your
standard Apple cool
core value is that we believe that
people with passion can change the world
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details